it was the kind of military spectacle
the world has become used to seeing in
north korea
perfectly choreographed with a vast
array of military hardware on show
and the usual statement of defiance from
the country's dictator
kim jong-un
we will continue to strengthen
self-defensive war deterrence
to deter control and manage all
dangerous attempts
and threatening acts including
ever-growing nuclear threats from
hostile forces
but it was the site of this weapon that
caused many international north korea
watchers to sit
up and take notice it appears to be a
new intercontinental ballistic missile
the largest and potentially most
powerful of its kind ever displayed by
pyongyang
and one that could pose a new threat to
the us and the international community
so like it or not nascar is a nuclear
power
and it's probably the third nuclear
power
which is capable of striking american
cities
third after russia in china
south korea responded by urging
pyongyang to commit to previous
agreements on disarmament
japan also expressed concern saying it
would continue to boost its military
defenses
i will refrain from mentioning various
individual missiles
but in general terms we are aware that
some new missiles make it difficult for
conventional equipment
to deal with
but for all the bravado on show in north
korea
analysts noted that kim jong-un also
appeared to be holding back
he's not yet tested the new weapon
leading some to say
it may not even work and that it could
be a tactic
to increase his leverage in any future
talks with the united states
for more on this i'm joined now by dr
sojin lim an analyst on north korean
affairs from the university of central
lancashire
in the uk dr lim welcome how much of a
cause of concern
would you say is this new missile
um as i see uh having the missile itself
uh is not much uh new thing for us
because that kind of tactics been there
uh for a long time
and especially uh we are waiting for the
november
uh presidency election in the states
and north korea especially is aiming to
see who will be the president and then
giving the message
to the states and it's not only
about the missile at the parade but it's
more about the kim jong-un's
state speech on the day he made it clear
that north korea will use these missiles
for
self-defense they will not uh have an
intention to
be pro provocative unless they don't
have any external challenges
so that means whoever it will be of the
president of the united states after
november
the north korea will be ready either be
provocative
or be a cooperative so they are giving
the message to the
united states in that sense it will be
really about how you present will um
show the kind of gesture to north korea
at the beginning
what is driving in north korea's nuclear
missile program i mean is it the
argument that look
if we don't develop weapons that can hit
the us hard
we won't be heard
for for north korea the nuclear program
or this kind of misses can be have been
the
bargaining uh power and also is a
survival rating survival tactics
for north korea they they have seen that
what happened
in iraq before in liberia or qadhafi
what happened after they gave up their
nuclear program
in the past so uh for for me it's really
not likely that north korea will give up
nuclear weapon entirely
unless they have any kind of
the tactics that they can develop
further to
maintain their resin for now the nuclear
program
is the uh one of the strongest um
pagani power for north korea that's why
i don't see
they will give it up in in soon near
future
where do you see negotiations with the
united states progressing
in the future dr lim
it will be really uh who will be the
president but as i see
both biden and trump are pretty much
interested in
talking with north korea recently biden
also mentions that if it's necessary he
has intention to meet
kim jong-un for trump of course it will
be another
layer of this theater tactic for
donald trump as a real uh tv show
program
so who whoever it would be for north
korea
u.s will continue to have a negotiation
and discussion about
over the nuclear program with north
korea
now north korea has been facing tough
u.n sections over its
missile program what does it say about
these sanctions
if north korea is able to create such a
missile despite
these sanctions
the situation is like in the past when
kim jong-il
or the kim jong's father kim jong-il was
there
they used nuclear power for food aid
so whenever they showed a missile test
or showed the nuclear program
development
then the so-called western allies
provided the food aid
rather than imposing a stronger power
sanctions but at the moment kim jong-un
north korea
is facing a stronger u.n
sanctions and kim jong-un tries to see
the way
how to get uh be away from it and for
example china and russia we know that
still provide
certain level of support to north korea
dr lim we'll leave it there thank you so
much for speaking to us
thank you